how important it is to to learn history
because in some way it dictates our
it can help our behavior it didn't help
viewers
no um no no i've lived um
hey i lived i lived that's the life just
like um
a lot of people you mentioned it may
have been a long time been hurt had a
life like remember we saw that movie
been heard
you know what i mean he was a wealthy
man he became a slave
he became a great conqueror as far as
athletics was concerned he became a star
he became a very he became the best
celebrity
and i believe wherever it was octavia
whatever city they took him to
he rescued that um he rescued the
general of that ship
and um after all that
he still went he still um couldn't save
his family they put him with the
leopards
and his main objective he went back and
he got his family from the leopards
his sister and his mother and then again
he came back
he may not have been um famous again
but he got his family and that was his
success we look at success
me myself you know it's different levels
of success some people's um
successes not using drugs not drinking
anymore
some people's successes making a million
dollars some other people's success is
making a billion dollars
some people's success is not going to
prison no more
you